on
[Applaudissements]
ppg delphine leplat alors elle devait
venir delphine wespiser wii et qui fait
la sienne est elle un tournage enfin
passons l'aiment bien nous on a
rencontré la veille à mon gamin cracher
dessus les rimes elle est là pour vous
dire comme elle est belle c'est la seule
en trente ans de fort boyard carrière
daunay la gaule au père fouras la fois
tu essayais je me suis consolé dans ok
on n'est pas là pour blaye et ces
messieurs
on n'est pas là par hasard pour réussir
il en est on est venu pour la
saint-valentin ratio mon gamin aurait un
message à faire passer
oui on a bien pu faire vous satisfait ça
vous pose un vrai problème mais comme je
vous aime
oui tout me demanderais shanty dacquois
est à +4
il a des gros problèmes et son amoureuse
voilà je voulais profiter de l'émission
en direct pour penser à mes sa chasse à
sa dulcinée à la danse était sale et
blanc allaient se voit pas et sont j'en
ai pour deux secondes c'était l'émission
allait regarder parler des millions de
gens tous les soirs mais moi je veux
m'adresser à sa seule personne
les boules damas
comme patricia ainsi pour la peine je
suis à l'aise dans la peau de ce pas une
seule personne qui peut qui prend une
très grosse plage dans ma vie et je sais
très gros et c'est sur 120 kg café ça
commence à prendre la place est vrai par
amour on déplace des montagnes mais là
c'est plus de la fidh
[Applaudissements]
pour que je le vois bien droit dans les
yeux à aller là où kalusha très mal
bourse alors claudine claudine bon bah
déjà bonjour jeu c'est forcément que tu
me regardes pas ce que tu tues tu aura
jamais une émission que les pêcheurs
allaient aly fall trilogy de tous à 100
moissac odile et claudine et j'ai un
message pour toi qui me sort du coeur
des fans au groupe c il est dans ma
poche mais là c'est ce que j'écris tout
ça sur lui quelques semaines il est là
dessus heureusement ne s'est pas
forcément que c'est pas lui qui a écrit
la bible parce qu'on aurait petit mot
les joues à pardon mon amour ma vie mon
soleil mccroquettes parce que c'est
comme ça que je l'appelle dans l'en dans
l'intimité sur ma petite trappe hérite
requête veut dire que tu es peinard et
qu'une croquettes comme ça tu pouvais en
fait une semaine dernière on peut
rigoler et christian à l'honneur
aujourd'hui pour la saint valentin
j'ai pris mon courage à deux mains parce
que faut pas remettre à demain ce qu'on
peut faire à la saint-valentin pirisiens
j'en suis formel je me souviens de toi
dans mon lit à l'époque c'était le
paradis
maintenant je suis tout seul avec ma
mère et crois moi tous les jours c'est
l'enfer au figaro
quand même c'est celle avec nîmes et à
l'évasion la ville claudine la vie sans
toi ce n'est que chagrin
c'est comme un grand feu qui s'est
éteint comme un bon repas change un bon
vin mais vous comme fort boyard champs
les nains gilet jaune sans son rond
point saint
2couper arrête de me couper tous à la
bouche
c'est ce que disait cyril le jour de la
circoncision rabat je sais je sais que
tu était bourré au réveillon
tu m'as trompée avec l'autre compte il
mais aujourd'hui je te pardonne d'avoir
dépassé les bornes
si tu me promet d'être fidèle je pense
le pont jma tourterelles robayo
[Musique]
qu'elle a compris le message claudine je
t'aime je voudrais que tu reviennes mais
je veux pas je veux pas que tu toute ma
vie moi je l'en genou j'aime mieux
dormir tout seul sur mes deux oreilles
que k2 sur ce sommet de corne
je veux pas de chapeau christian 7 en
bouche un coin hein c'est pas que ça ma
bouche un coin c'est que ça me troue le
cul alors c'était pas prévu mais du coup
moi ça me donne une petite idée de dire
si j'ai je passe une annonce aussi du
coup pourquoi les patients après tout
j'aime moi je suis commune et gilet
jaune 1 j'en ai marre de tir elio par la
queue à avec ma pauvre retraite de
misère alors je me disais en écoutant
son petit message après tout comme il ya
des jeunes qui s'emballe des cougars
pour leur pognon
pourquoi que je serai pas le contraire
c'est à dire c'est pourquoi je m'emballe
répondent les petits jeunes pour leur
pognon aussi alors c'est si c'est vrai
alors en deux mots pour arrondir mes
fins de mois
cyril hanouna voudrais-tu de me pousser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez alors je serais magicien
oui tu nous es tu peux réfléchir mais
c'est vrai après tout cinq ans il paraît
qui joue bien au tennis je voudrais pas
me mettre un grand coup droit dormagen
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chef avec
[Musique]
alors maria kirilenko qui souffre
oui mais pas ou pire chicha dénonce-t-il
ah c'est vrai moi j'aime bien le jeu
note a des yeux magnifiques ainsi un
beau corps tu es bien cambrai moi je
prends la belle poitrine à kelly oui
l'arrière train à nabila way cynique à
la tringle accroché je peux te faire
monter au rideau est ce que tu peux vous
dire exactement ce que tu veux pour les
téléspectateurs ou à l'epo pour ma
famille alors la famille chance repos
une affaire parce que c'est clair c'est
net c'est par intérêt un accord puis
actuelle l'oseille durerait tu mets ton
l'oseille dans mes épinards
c'est ça non voudrais tu m'épouser fait
un bisou d'abord ouais ça bonjour je
vous respecte trop c'est vrai sans
déconner c'est oui
[Applaudissements]
la grille à habas sa valeur réseau
compte
moi j'suis pas carlos ghosn se paye
repos à un mariage aux frais de la
princesse versailles alors qu'ici on
s'arrangera tous les deux on se rappelle
on se rappelle mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
alors on est mariés c'est bon oui c'est
bon ah oui pour toi été atteint et doute
là dessus c'est pas embrasser ses bras
[Applaudissements]
je porte je pense est-ce que c'est pas
mieux qu'on fasse on consomme après je
me tends mais je me demande si c'est à
nous qu'on fasse tout dans la foulée
quoi rime et chez les plats qui sont me
jetait comme moi faut les consommer il
fait tout bien
oui c'est me concentre maintenant oui
oui y'a pas de pub est un héros on va
arrêter parce que je sais très bien que
ton coeur appartient à quelqu'un mais
alors non nous ne vous leurrez pas lui
voler à cette personne un malheur parce
que l'amour y'a qu'ça c'est le plus beau
moi je vais vous dire j'ai eu un seul
amour de ma vie c'était mon raymond je
savais c'est le jour de sa mort que je
t'ai compris que c'était l'homme de ma
vie
ah ouais bah oui mais pas le rôle assez
comme ça un petit peu tard oui oui c'est
que je t'aime que sémou cyril maman et
orbi
[Applaudissements]
gfr
c'est pour mon truc d'arthur non le
partage et la sauge après choc c'est un
peu comme la toussaint je me demande si
c'est pour interflora carter ça pour
vendre des fleurs le jem sari faire
mouche et christian l'amour le vrai
ouais c'est pas forcément celui qui
t'offre des fleurs tous les jours ce que
c'est surtout celui qui te coupe les
ongles des pieds quand tu peux plus de
baisser
[Rires]
tiens j'ai un dernier petit message je
lai promise et me marier avec mes deux
vieilles ma fripé gens voient ce choeur
à ma petite camille qui élabore dans les
montagnes je salue son grand courage
accroche-toi la vie est belle ma cocotte
elle mérite d'être vécue sexuelle